The 2016 film passengers was advertised
as a high concept science fiction
blockbuster about a romance in space.
Based on that,
I was excited to see it.
Unfortunately, the central premise
doesn't make for a very good love story.
In fact, it has much more in
common with a horror film.
Jim is a passenger, a board, a star ship,
making the long journey to another
planet when a malfunction wakes him from
hibernation too early and where are we?
We are in transit from Earth to homestead
to we will arrive in approximately 90
years.
Wow.
It seems he's destined to live and die
alone on the ship before anyone else
wakes up trapped by his circumstances.
Jim starts obsessing over another
sleeping passenger named Aurora
intent on pursuing a
romantic relationship.
Jim Sabotage has her hibernation pod
and makes it look like an accident
from Aurora's perspective.
This is a story about a strange man who
imprisons her alone with him in space
forever. This stranger robs
her of her life, her future,
and her self determination.
And yet because this movie is
supposed to be a love story,
how audiences are meant to
feel sympathetic to Jim and
root for the relationship
to work out
the films.
Science fiction setting tends to obscure
the fact that passengers is an example
of a very old and deeply
troubling media convention.
Abduction as romance.
Abduction is romances, immediate trope
where a man kidnaps were in prisons,
a woman, and then she eventually
falls in love with him.
Like a lot of storytelling conventions,
abduction as a romance isn't new.
It can be traced all the way back to
ancient literature and it was a favorite
plot device in classic Hollywood.
Yeah,
they must
be terribly in love. I want you to make
me angry. I always knew where you were.
A nasty, vulgar role. In
some versions of the trope,
men abduct women for the
purpose of finding love.
Courtship I a little more
strenuous than I like it,
but in most cases the woman is kidnapped
for some other reason and the romance
only blossoms after she's forced
to spend time with her. Abductor.
If you try and move our climb off the bed,
I'll know I'll feel it
and I promise you are
the kidnapping or
hostage situation itself.
Maybe short lived waste,
sunny and their romance may
not have a happy ending,
but the abductor is always framed
as a decent guy in the end.
It can be a pretty likable guy and I'm
not pointing a gun at somebody I know.
Don't believe me, but it's
true. You've got to trust me.
The plot device is especially popular
with screenwriters because kidnapping
scenarios provide a quick and easy
way to bring two unlikely characters
together.
May I just say in advance that I am sorry.
Sorry for walks.
Now, if I'm not mistaken, this means you
have to come with me but make no mistake.
These are narratives in which men who
violate women's rights and autonomy are
then rewarded with a romantic relationship
who don't like to be pushed any bread
and last June and drug into buses in the
middle of the night.
Abduction is romance can be
found in all kinds of media
including romance films and
comedies. Well, I'm asking you,
I can't believe this is happening.
This is not a joke anymore.
I'm thinking that flute called
kidnapping if you want to be rude.
And even in classic musicals like
seven brides for seven brothers.
Oh,
they acted angry and annoyed,
but secretly they was all her joy
by Oh that when corral and yours,
but it's especially popular
in action adventures, genres,
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Bruce Willis
Star in three separate movies each where
they have romantic relationships
with the women they've kidnapped.
Yeah,
we see this with Swarts and niggers
characters in the running man.
I break your neck like a chicken
and then again in commando getting the
call and then again to his own wife.
In true lies,
Bruce Willis has characters hold their
love interests hostage and bandits in the
critically acclaimed film,
12 monkeys and then more recently in red
audiences are meant to view the danger
that these men pose has an essential part
of what makes them
exciting and attractive.
These are men of action.
They take control and take
what they want and in the car
with violence if necessary.
Now you'll notice that with
very few exceptions, these
kidnappers are white men.
Ho mainstream western audiences tend to
give violent white guys the benefit of
the doubt to keep your hands high Pothier
while rarely extending that same level
of sympathy to men of color. In similar
situations, which I know everybody
on the floor don't kill me,
like most media tropes,
there are variations on the theme.
There's the accidental kidnapping that
later becomes a real one. Keep your head,
turn your legs all the time.
There's the clueless criminal
who doesn't know what he's doing.
You're the worst kidnapper I've ever met.
I'm trying to do my best it under
really difficult circumstances,
and then there's the Hitman
who falls for his mark.
But the underlying pattern in all of
these abduction as romance narratives
revolves around men exercising
complete control over women.
Come on please.
A theme that's reinforced by the inclusion
of scenes where I'm man forcibly puts
an otherwise independent
woman in her place.
I learned a long time ago,
my lady never trust a mountain
catch when she stops snowing.
Never Trust a woman when
your back is turned.
Indeed the abducted women are rarely
portrayed as passive. Damsels.
Are you picking me for a ride?
You're not going to move and you're going
to keep your trap shut or I'll let you
have cheap.
I always thought the
day you've got a stupid,
even though these women are
written to be Feisty, oh,
they're often framed as being a little
too feisty for their own good to be a
little too feisty for your own good,
which provides our kidnapper
the opportunity to assert
his power and control.
Am I go sound?
Do you understand by
aggressively silencing her
by anyone that likes the food
when they are not alone? No. Oh. Oh.
Audiences are treated the scene after
scene fetishizing the domination and
disempowerment of women.
If she tries to turn the
tables on her abductor,
he remains unfazed and her attempts
to intimidate him don't work.
Okay.
In some cases, when he reasserts
his control by disarming her,
it's framed as an act of seduction.
No kidnapping and false imprisonment
are almost universally understood to be
reprehensible crimes.
And because of that,
abduction is widely regarded as an act
of villainy and definitely not something
the good guy would do.
This means that screenwriters need to
find some way to make the kidnapper into a
sympathetic character. Hey, okay.
One way this is done is by giving the
abductor a moment of basic human decency.
It can be as simple as offering his
hostage something to eat or drink, drink,
or maybe allowing her
to go to the bathroom.
I need a little help or not
sexually assaulting her.
We tell you something,
even though I haven't a bit lately,
I'm gonna Force myself on. You. Never
done that in my life. I'm not. No kidding.
Come Howard from the calm of just
trying to explain to you that there's no
sexual motives for my actions.
That's an impressively low bar for men
when it comes to being seen as a nice
guy. You seem like a nice guy.
You're not like the others.
You have to do what's right for you.
Another way.
The abductor is reframed as heroic is
by juxtaposing his violence against the
actions of even more violent men.
Other the bad guys.
Worse guys hold my neck.
Writers also attempt to
justify the kidnapping itself
by framing it as necessary.
No, no problem with it either as
something done for the greater good,
like saving the world or is something
done for the victims owned good,
usually saving her life in some way.
Just let me go
safe not safe.
That variation is so common that there's
a whole sub category of movies in which
a heroic rescue doubles as a kidnapping.
To illustrate how these rescue
slash kidnapping scenarios work,
let's analyze the brief abduction from
the original 1984 terminator movie.
Kyle Reese travels back in time and
save Sarah Connor from the terminator,
but during the getaway, he makes it
aggressively clear that his help is not
optional.
Do exactly what I say exactly.
I don't move unless I say, don't
make a sound in this. I say,
do you understand?
Do you understand?
Please do.
You told her.
Notice that in stories like this,
the man typically holds all the cards.
He alone understands the true danger
that she's in and he alone knows how to
survive. Then you are from
the future too. Is that right?
Right.
The insidious thing about scenes like
this one is that they're written to twist
a man's abusive behavior
into a heroic act of love.
Just listen.
Understand that terminator is out there
and it absolutely will not stop ever
chill.
You are dead.
The narrative is specifically designed
so that we as the audience will view
Kyle's aggression towards Sarah as
both a reasonable and necessary.
Can you stop it? The
storytelling trick here, okay.
To set up an elaborate scenario in
which a woman's perfectly reasonable and
rational resistance to male violence seems
like a naive mistake and that framing
is not accidental.
It's a specific kind of male fantasy
where a man taking away a woman's freedom
and fundamental rights. He was presented
as something done for her own good,
which results in situations where she
becomes dependent on her abductor for
survival. Just so you understand
right now out there on your own.
Your life expectancy is like with me,
without me here with me,
without me, with me, without
one of the worst examples of this.
Abduction for her own good framing can
be found in the movie version of V for
Victor Data.
Our hero kidnaps Evy,
makes her believe that she's been caught
by the fascist government and proceeds
to torture her mercilessly.
It's whenever you want,
just tell us where he is.
These abhorring actions are framed as
necessary because it's only through being
tortured for days on end that
Evie learns how to be strong.
Not only does she forgive
him for torturing her,
she thanks him for it and then the to
go on to share a series of romantic
moments.
I always sample a bottle
of wine before I buy it.
Let's have a sip if
you're worth taking along.
Let's not mince words here.
Abduction as romance is an abuse trip.
All of the male characters that we've
been discussing engage in what domestic
violence prevention organizations
describe as red flag behaviors cures.
So I think it's instructive to quickly
go over a few of them in detail.
Physical force abusers will resort
to the use of force strand conflicts.
This can include restraining
or holding down their partner.
These actions are often accompanied
by demands that the victim
shut your mouth.
Threats of violence abusers will threaten
their partners with violence as a
means of coercion rock and bring it down
on your head so hard that a substance
resembling guacamole is going to come
out of your ears. Controlling behavior.
Abusers will attempt to control or
restrict their partner's movements and to
make decisions for them. Let's go now.
This is usually done under
the guise of protection
and finally the one that's
most central to the abduction.
As Romance trope isolation abusers will
try to isolate the victim from friends,
family,
or even the outside world.
This often includes restricting
the use of communication devices.
Each of these actions is considered a
red flag for an abusive relationship.
And most of the male characters
in abduction as romance
movies check off several
of these boxes.
Even the less explicitly violent
abductors like Jim from passengers still
isolate and control their vision.
Dennis,
regardless of the
intentions of the writers,
these narratives end up both excusing
and romanticizing the violent behavior of
abusive men.
No discussion of abduction as romance
would be complete without mention of
beauty and the beast, especially the
two enormously popular Disney movies,
both of which include a
version of this trope.
The beast holds the life of Belle's
father in his hands and in order to save
him,
Doug Bell trades away her own freedom
and agree is to be in prison forever in
the beast's castle.
Now pop criticism of beauty and the
beast often focuses on something called
Stockholm syndrome,
which is a psychological phenomenon
where in a kidnapping victim comes to
sympathize with their kidnapper.
However,
it's not part of how I'm defining
the abduction as romance trope.
And that's because of focus on Stockholm
Syndrome tends to shift the blame away
from the perpetrator and onto the victim,
which then works to undermine the
female character by implying she's been
brainwashed.
As I mentioned before,
many of the abducted or imprisoned women
in these movies are actually shown to
be quite brave, especially
given their perilous situations.
Many of them tried to
escape and some succeed,
but regardless the victim and her
motivations are not the problem with this
trope.
The problem stems entirely from
the abductor and his actions.
After all, it's the beast who in
prisons, Bell isolates her verbally,
berates her
and even for bids her from eating at month
I tall.
Despite all of this abusive behavior,
the beast is still framed
as a misunderstood nice guy
and he still gets the girl
in the end.
Story is like this,
carry with them some insidious
messages about men and masculinity.
Chief among them is the idea that abusive
men just need to meet the right woman,
someone so special that the promise of
her love will magically cure him of his
violent ways and make him a better person.
Now it is possible to read these stories
as being about the forgiveness and
redemption of troubled men,
which in some ways they are.
Unfortunately,
these redemption arks play out in
ways that end up reinforcing some very
pernicious myths about domestic abuse.
Abusive men don't
suddenly change overnight,
especially not after a lifetime of it
being a dick.
Men with a history of violent
behavior don't spare their loved ones.
On the contrary,
domestic violence statistics show that
intimate partners and family members bear
the brunt of their tanks.
In the movies.
We're usually expected to assume that
these abduction romances we'll end happily
ever after.
Yeah,
but in the real world,
love affairs like this would likely
lead to abusive relationships.
This is because the strongest predictor
of domestic violence is previous acts of
abuse.
In fact,
men with a history of committing violence
against women are 13 times more likely
to repeat that behavior in the future.
Psychologists refer to these patterns of
repeat behavior as the cycle of abuse.
Once an abusive episodes stops,
it's often followed by a honeymoon phase
where the abuser will show remorse,
promise not to do it again,
and then acting kind,
even loving ways for a while at least.
But inevitably that will be followed
by a tension building phase,
which then culminates in
another abusive episode.
She'll keep you more time.
I show keep you on
responding to my patient.
Your hatred will kill Linda
for that day.
Dawns folk shows
and the cycle continues.
The first step in breaking the cycle is
often for the survivor to get away from
the abuser.
Now,
it is possible for violent men to
change their pattern of behavior,
although it's an extremely difficult
process requiring years of therapy,
but that's rarely how
it happens in Hollywood.
In the movies we've been talking about,
abusive men are miraculously
transformed by finding true love
and they gain forgiveness for their
crimes through a single act of heroism.
This means they're never really held
accountable for the harm they've inflicted
on.
Okay.
Real redemption requires taking
responsibility for your actions.
It requires doing the slow,
often painful work of self transformation.
The bottom line is it's not possible
to fix violent men by loving them in
exactly the right way,
but that's the idea at the heart
of the abduction is romance trope.
It's the kind of twisted Hollywood logic
that can lead people of all genders to
remain in abusive relationship.
Yeah.
The abduction as romance Trobe needs to
be retired onscreen relationships can
bloom from any number of
dramatic or exciting scenarios.
There really is no reason for writers
to continue romanticizing abusive male
behavior.
Thanks for watching these long form video
essays take an enormous amount of time
to write research and produce,
so if you'd like to see more of them,
please consider going over to Patrion
and helping to fund this project there.
There's also a link to paypal
in the description below.
I'll see you all again very
soon with another episode.
Examining the intersections of
masculinity, politics, and media.